[Music]
five years ago thanos erased half of the
universe but the people of this planet
brought everyone back
with a snap of a finger
humanity once believed we were gods
with what this planet now faces
they will believe again
eternal is assembled
what's the plan
we fight
marvel studios eternals repeat 13 only
appears november 5th you are about to
meet the greatest warriors the world has
ever known
legendary
fashionable
powerful
[Music]
well i'm sure that was a lot of fun for
you it was on november 5th the marvel
universe play nice becomes eternal so
what's your superpower
you know that your babysitting
privileges are completely revoked right
marvel studios eternal sweetie pg-13
only peter's november 5th
[Music]
five years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe
not the people of this planet brought
everyone back with a snap of a finger
the sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin
how long do we have
seven days
we're eternals
[Music]
we came here seven thousand years ago
to protect humans from the deviants
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
[Music]
we were instructed not to interfere in
any human conflicts and estevians are
involved
by who
[Music]
we need to find the others
i haven't seen some of them for
centuries
hi
hello
this is what the end of the world looks
like
at least we have front row seats
you know what's never saved the planet
you're sarcasm
[Music]
[Applause]
we have loved these people since the day
we arrived
when you love something
you protect it
[Applause]
you can't protect
any of them
[Music]
i bet you've built the perfect safe
house what's this even made of vibranium
fall collection
ikea
[Music]
you